[Applause]
I'm a black male I've gone through this
my whole life
never asked for any of it it's a big
problem but the smaller problems that go
on every single day that people need to
understand that this is how small
problems become big problem
I can't have my two are walking around
thinking this is okay this is not okay
it's definitely not okay and I don't
want her to fall like anywhere she goes
in the world from today onwards it's
going to be a problem for her there'll
be a lot of people watching this and
looking at all of you guys there and
think that whatever you do there's a
pandemic and you're all pretty much
putting yourself at risk we open
ourselves at risk because for me
personally I believe in is that
important it needs to be heard and we
need to take a stand
black lives matter yes water but right
now with this matter all right
that's right if black lives don't matter
what is it right that you did you don't
black man every day it's not easy right
amount of times that I've been that I
[Music]
went experience you know racist comments
I feel guilty that I've not done
anything vocally to help the people who
are oppressed and they've been
oppressing so long and they deserve so
much war and it makes me emotional
because everyone bought their stands
told people in their car throwing their
horns
[Music]
I feel great I'm proud of everybody they
came out here representing black people
black class in only just never known in
the world only in America not all in the
UK everywhere in the UK we've had a lot
of discrimination with the police for a
long long time
no circumstances well happily George
Ford was correct that's why the people
are hot in London didn't happen in
London by could happen
[Applause]
without a long beam tensions between
many communities here in the UK and the
police but it's not as bad as it is in
America is it
that's like saying someone's got
stage-four pants on another person's got
stage-four pants on telling the person
who stage free not to worry but there's
someone else in stage 4 it's still pants
are still a problem and still racism in
full effect and I
[Applause]
yes cool I smell right now
no of what race is being killed time and
time and time and time again everyone's
had enough enough is enough
[Applause]